the graph below shows the relationship
between hours of exercise and hours of
screen time for a group of five friends
on thursday
so if we look over here
we can see that here on
this horizontal axis when we're going
from the left to right it says hours of
exercise so half an hour one hour one
and a half hours two hours two and a
half hours and then here it shows hours
of screen time so for example looks like
liu yang
did zero hours of exercise did no
exercise and spent seven hours in front
of a screen
not something that i would recommend
and it looks like kavitha spent half an
hour had half an hour of exercise
on thursday this is all describing what
happens on thursday it had five and a
half hours of screen time you see that
right over there and we could keep going
with all the other
data points
but let's see what they're asking us
what is the meaning of the point marked
maxime i think that's how i would
pronounce that so maxime is right over
here and it looks like this is the point
one
because our horizontal coordinate right
over here is one and then our vertical
coordinate is four so point one comma
four and this one is the hours of
exercise so maxima exercises one hour
one hour
exercise
and
they spend four hours in front of a
screen on that thursday
four hours
screen time screen
time all right so let's see which of
these choices say that
let's see it is
maximum maxima had one hour of exercise
and four hours of screen time yep this
looks exactly right and if you just
wanted to check the other ones maxime
had two hours of exercise
two hours of exercise and eight hours of
screen time that would put them way up
here and that's not where the point was
so we'd rule that out maxie may had four
hours of exercise and one hour of screen
time four hours of exercise it's not
even on this on we'd have to go off the
screen so we'd rule that one out
next we had five hours of exercise once
again that's not even on the screen here
so that is
so we can rule all of them out this
third choice they're actually trying to
confuse you because
they're swapping the hours of exercise
and screen time maxima has one hour of
exercise four hours of screen time not
four hours of exercise and one hour of
screen time